there's somebody around the president of
the United States at all times with the
nuclear football and all that means is
that's true yeah wherever wherever the
president is he has the ability to
initiate or to defend an attack so if
North Korea nukes Hawaii right he can go
into the code book and read off the
codes and go through the proper channels
they have checks and balances but they
that's why you have the nuclear football
following the president everywhere he
goes day and night and it's handcuffed
to uh military attache and
uh the reason this is making me laugh is
just because I love that humans are just
so human like I love the guy who you
know has the co has it handcuffed to him
how do you get that job like the guy
who's like hell man like how did I it
was all because Tony back in 1947 left
the briefcase
somewhere why does it have to be handcut
I mean it's go Tony Tony there Tony
where's the briefcase he's like oh I
left it in the diner they're like
fucking handcuffing to Tony so every
morning
he like we're do I have to yes Tony you
do so he goes to the when he goes to the
bathroom he's got the
brief
yeah all because some dickhead back in
the day hold on left it I mean so does
it's just like a does it when they
switch shifts is it like yeah yeah an
eight hour shift I'm assuming M yeah I
there's like what if you like meet a
girl and like on your break oh but
you're not on a break you're right by
the presid okay you're just holding the
briefcase you're sitting there like this
but how do you get that job is it it's a
military you're in the military you're
the Air Force Navy or I feel like it's
you are pointed because if it's a job
you want it's not a job they should let
you have right I think they they have
all kinds of attaches assigned to the
White House he is the commanderin-chief
so he's got to be able to communicate so
he's got a staff of but since we have it
it's the kind of thing where it's like
you know you got to start a car a
vintage car you know once a month so
that when you do start it at works like
yeah do they have drills all the time
okay they have drills they have to go
around and make sure I'm obsessed if
like we need the nuclear codes we like
oh we never we didn't we weren't codes
Cod codes codes go you Bob you had I did
I did there was a software update did I
in the plug did is it plugged in okay
where are they they're downloading sir
download hold on one second I'm getting
the spinny wheel I'm getting are you on
Wi-Fi I just can we can Dro Wii so I can
get on you have a Samsung you can't have
a Sam you've got the codes our
satellites are so good theirs and so are
theirs our adversaries are China and
Russia they're they Park their
satellites over the top of the United
States in a geosync uh so as the United
States spins their satellites just hover
over us so they're watching us 24/7
we're doing the same to them and and we
can we can see missiles coming and going
think that's I spotting sometimes might
be which by the way that's the story of
the freaking Century that no one gives
to about no one cares like it's like
shiny Keys over here meanwhile aliens
Landing UFOs we've acknowledged them now
you know it's all good I have a theory
because that no one wants to um uh pay
the like pay wall like I literally would
go to like the Wall Street Journal it'd
be like are do we have aliens and' be
like $2.99 like I'm not going to put in
my credit someone will tell me about it
you know about it I don't know if I
bought it I I believe aliens are out
there some I don't think those when you
see flying saucers and stuff do you
think some of that is other countries
surveillance and satellites and stuff
yes I think I think uh um uh I I don't
know I think there's UFOs unidentified
flying objects yes for sure we've got
the we got the proof but I don't know I
haven't seen an alien yet yeah no one's
part no one's made contact no there
haven't been any conversations there
haven't been any handshakes so until
that happens come on I it's interesting
there was um I think it was in the
Atlantic an article about how um
basically we get our ideas from it's
actually us it's actually people that
write movies and make movies like we
decided they were going to be green and
look the way they look so that's what
we're looking for but if you're like a
an advanced extraterrestrial your
spaceship is going to just look like an
airplane yeah or a crow well and if you
also if you think people wouldn't lie
about this I'm like guys people have all
kinds of motives for doing what they do
I watched an interview of a man being
interviewed who had had alien contact
okay this was shot in the 1950s okay and
he was like he's like he was a it was it
was a genuine news report so he's this
man's out there and he's like can you
tell me what you experienced well they
were just like us they came off and he
said his name was you know x-ray 10,000
and he was a nice man we shook hands he
walked around I explained the crops that
I was growing he said thank you and he
got back up so he spoke English he was a
homo sapien sure you know you know and
he got back on his spacecraft after
having a pleasant conversation with you
and just departed okay like I'm sorry I
don't believe that also it's like why
are all they all naked it seems like I
feel like they would have figured out
clothes if they could figure out how to
move that fast they would have figured
out how to disguise themselves as clouds
or something that we see anyway all the
time I think they're not going to look
like what we think they're going to look
like they probably look either so human
that we would never know they weren't or
Not Human at all I feel like right I
think a lot of it beyond our beyond our
conception
I they're going to be like we're not
going to look like the weird puppet that
was in ight Shyamalan signs we're not
doing that and just this this solar
system alone what I don't listen also
you can spend you can spend all your
time overthinking this shit I would love
to or yes please what are you get with
the life add to cart no thank you add to
cart